hi
so today i wanted to talk about my
favorite podcast in neuroscience and
even though i study neuroscience myself
i find it really hard to keep up with
the literature sometimes because there's
just so much new knowledge coming out
every day so that's why i think podcasts
are a great way to just keep engaged
with the field and also to learn about
new topics and interesting little
nuggets that you don't really get from
dry papers so yeah i want to give you a
list of podcasts that i personally
really enjoyed in neuroscience and
hopefully you'll find one that you like
as well so let's get right into it so
the first podcast i really like is the
uberman lab podcast and dr hubermann is
a neuroscientist from stanford that's
now also a tenured professor so then you
already know you're kind of good and the
topics he talks about are more related
to neurobiology so he talks a lot about
hormones and different
neural endocrine systems that i don't
personally know that much about and
that's why i really like and enjoy his
podcast and i do have to say the focus
of his topics are a little bit more
self-help so for example how to optimize
your sleep or how to get better focus or
how to get a healthier brain so to speak
but the way he tackles the topics are in
a really principled manner so i do think
he explains the neuroscience really well
even though he picks topics that are
more considered a little bit popular in
media so two episodes that i really
enjoyed was um adhd and how anyone can
improve their focus and i really enjoyed
this topic because especially in the
current attention economy people are
really losing their ability to focus
myself included and we're just scrolling
on twitter and youtube all day which
you're doing right now i guess but
anyways so yeah i think this was a
really good topic for me to kind of
relearn some of the systems that are
involved in our brains when we're trying
to focus and then the next podcast i
really like is kind of related to this
one i found it through the hubermann lab
podcast so it's the podcast called
lifespan by david sinclair and i love
this podcast because david sinclair is a
geneticist so he's not really a
neuroscientist but he talks about how
we should view aging as a disease and
not a necessary premise of life and when
you first hear this idea you're kind of
like is he trying to play god or
whatever but he goes into this topic so
carefully and he really explains all the
genetic pathways and epigenetic pathways
that are involved in aging and
especially in our field a lot of older
people suffer from alzheimer's or
dementia and i think these are such
troubling disorders and he says
that all these disorders can be caught
under one big disorder which is aging
and if you solve aging you would solve
these sub disorders or these sub
diseases and i think it's a really
interesting and really brave idea i'm
not sure if i fully agree with it but i
would recommend you to listen to his
podcast it's really interesting okay
then the next podcast i want to talk
about is a little bit more serious in a
sense it's called brain science by
ginger compel and
ginger compel interviews really
prominent researchers in neuroscience
and i do think his podcast is maybe a
little bit difficult if you never had
any experience with neuroscience i'm not
too sure but i love the guest c
interviews because they're really
interesting speakers or nurse scientists
that have written books for example that
you usually don't get a chance to meet
that often or to ask questions and
throughout an episode he just asked
questions and they really dived into
some topics that are quite controversial
or quite interesting one episode i
really loved was with antonio dimasio
and that's the author of feeling and
knowing so they explored the origin of
consciousness and its evolution and i
personally love the
subject consciousness i think it's a
really controversial subject in
neuroscience nowadays so yeah it's it's
really fun to listen to that then the
next podcast i really love is a lot more
fun it's the mind's brain body project
by paul taylor and paul taylor is just a
funny host i think they make a lot of
jokes and it's a little bit more a
self-help podcast i would say so paul
taylor does have a lot of knowledge but
the way they speak and the way they joke
around it's just a really easy listen so
i loved his wisdom wednesdays on sleep
and aging and also the neuroscience of
enduring change with richard lane so
yeah he really tackles some topics that
i find interesting more to apply in
daily life and less in a higher
cognitive level or something like that
so the next podcast is one of my
favorite podcasts it's called nause by
ian goodman or news i'm not i'm not too
sure and i really love his podcast i
find ian goodman is such a good host so
he invites different neuroscientists as
well but the way he talks with them and
the way he speaks is just really
engaging and it makes
it a really easy listen even though the
topics he discusses are usually
quite difficult i think he has a really
good base and a really easy voice so i
loved his podcast with edward bulmore on
the inflamed mind theory of depression
so this theory says that one of the
causes of depression could be an
inflamed mind and without an inflamed
body and that usually comes from
sickness or illness and i thought that
this was a really interesting theory i
personally don't think all depression
comes from this but they also don't say
that in the podcast it would be
interesting to research this further i
love this one and also i love the one
with gina rippon on the myth of the
gendered brain and i decided to read her
book afterwards and gina rippon is just
such a good researcher she's a really
engaging speaker as well so i highly
recommend listening to that episode if
you're interested in that talk the only
sad thing about this podcast is that he
hasn't been making any episodes recently
i'm not really sure why i haven't dug
into it but if you know um let me know
down in the comments then i kind of want
to go into some subjects that are
related to neuroscience but not
neuroscience themselves and podcasts
related to that so one of the podcasts i
really love is philosophized this by
stephen west and philosophy for me is
really a key component in knowing
neuroscience and being able to talk
about neuroscience because a lot of our
origins in thinking come from philosophy
so also in a lot of theories of
neuroscience but also of psychology you
see these old philosophy premises still
existing in the theories so for example
you have from renee descartes the
dualism and this is still a really
relevant subjects in debates on
consciousness so i think it's good to
get some knowledge on philosophy if
you're doing any type of science and
stephen west makes it really easy to
understand and to listen to and also
when you listen to him you just feel
really smart so that's also really
important of course so i personally
loved his episode from sartre and camus
on consciousness is freedom sartre is
one of the philosophers that i
personally find really interesting and
also of course his episode 95 are you
living in a simulation so this is the
idea of the boltzmann brain actually
which is thought of by cosmologists and
i think it's personally a really
interesting idea and it could actually
be true if you just look at the math and
do a thought experiment you could
possibly be living in a simulation so
yeah that's also an interesting listen
and then the last podcast that i found
recently that i really enjoy is on
physics and it's from shane carroll's
it's called mindscape and shane carroll
is a theoretical physicist and
philosopher who specializes in quantum
theory and also in gravity and cosmology
so
you already know the topics are going to
be a little interesting and quite
difficult i think and one episodes that
i loved that was more neuroscience
related was with anal seth on the
emergence information and consciousness
and anal seth for me is a really
interesting researcher i'm reading his
book right now on consciousness but in
general shane carroll's talk and podcast
is just so fun he talks about dark
energy and quantum fields and just all
these topics that you're like i feel
really smart listening to this so yeah i
would highly recommend listening to that
podcast as well so these were my
podcasts that i really enjoy in
neuroscience i'm curious if you have
some podcasts that i didn't name them
down in the comments below because i
always love discovering new podcasts and
otherwise see you next week bye